Ah!
It's like I just started again.
We're back on the tomato farm.
Oh.
Here we are.
Back on the farm.
Oh, I had to get rid of my old skin suit.
So we're here as a tomato again.
My true form.
so anyway I didn't really have a time to get a new skin suit
to put on and my old one is in the trash can over there so I
have to dig it out real quick uh yeah you know what's the
best part I can actually have a logo on the trash can I'm
not even monetized anyway like what's gonna They're gonna
demonetize me because I have a logo on a trash can.
I'm not even monetized anyway
The best part I Google dumpster.
Oh, is it copyright free?
Well, well, those are really mad ain't
As long as it's a PNG That's all I need.
Oh my god.
Anyway, guys, let me...
Let me go change real quick.
Let me go change real quick into my...
Into my old... old suit.
It's a little fucking dirty, though.
Give me a sec, guys.
Give me a sec.
I gotta go change real quick.
Alright.
Gotta change into my old suit.
Just like old times.
Just like old times Well Here I go
Alright guys I did warn you guys It was gonna be incredibly
scuffed Like now
I didn't worry you guys It was gonna be incredibly scuffed I
had two days I had two days
I'm just Alright back then I used to talk like this
but now I lost my youthful optimism and now I know the real
world so now I talk like this but yes I am back now I am
back at as I dokey I've grown up I realize life is it's not
as It's not as sunny as I thought it was gonna be
The more I see reality The lower my voice got But But I
think I cried enough And I think I cried enough, that's for
sure I had like an entire month To do that So obviously
obviously I'm okay I oh okay to be fair to be fair I won't
say I'm okay to be to be fair I am but I am surviving I am
surviving and I really okay also we gotta get off the farm
I'm not tomato anymore so we gotta we gotta get off the farm
real quick give me a sec there you go yeah
wow isn't this familiar Wow.
Doki, where's the slides?
Where's the $3,000 lore debut video?
Where's the...
Where's like all the pretty slides and all your information?
I got...
I don't think I have...
Guys.
There's no way I had time to put all that up and do things.
um but but thank you you know what we have though oh shit
not like that though oh my gosh not the zoom thing but what
we have is obs text that's what we have so that's where all
information is gonna go anyway for those for those who are
hoping for me to make another statement that will be at the
end of the stream so if you want the last statement i would
say it in the end of the stream for now for now let's just
let's just i i haven't stream for a month plus i i i haven't
streamed in like so long i don't even honestly i don't even
remember how to do all of this like i don't even know i had
to plug in my four to five year old PC to get all my old old
graphics and everything because I I and then I had to plug
in some fucking Overwatch keyboard just to be like because I
was the only keyboard with a cable it was so dusty it was
like that keyboard was like seven years old I it was it was
a lot it was It was a lot.
It's like, I was like, where, what?
I didn't even organize any of those files.
It was just all in one download file.
I was like, it was in a download.
Okay, everything, I put everything in a downloads folder
because back then, four years ago, Doki, never give a fuck
about organizing anything.
So everything was just in a folder called downloads.
So then I was like, what the fuck did I used so i had to
deal with that for a bit and then and then i was like oh my
oh my god okay it was just oh my god and then all these new
technology god i'm oh my god this girl got potential thank
you thank you i really i really appreciate that anyway So,
um, it's just, it's a lot.
I really, I saw how many people were in the waiting room,
and I was like, oh, fuck, okay.
I haven't, like, talked to this many people in so long.
I, all right, you guys want to know my schedule before then?
This was my schedule before then.
7 p.m.
I wake up It's 7 p.m.
I I eat lunch I eat lunch I play video games It's 4 a.m.
I eat dinner
And then I play until I'm so fucking tired that I pass out.
That was the most healthiest schedule I had for almost a
month straight.
Wasn't that?
And so what I saw, I saw was like, oh my god, now it's it.
Don't make it depressing.
Toki, don't take it.
don't make it depressing toky please they want to watch
anime girls to escape from reality i'm sorry i need to i
need to get back into a group of things guys i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry Anyway.
Alright.
You know what's funny?
I actually just came back from therapy.
And yeah.
I have weekly therapy now.
Because you know.
That definitely sounded so healthy.
So.
Anyway.
I came back from therapy.
And then my therapist was like.
Wow.
Doki.
You are.
You sound so different.
And I was like.
Yeah, I got 32 days together.
I was like...
Yeah.
But like, I can...
I can do stuff now.
So...
And then...
And but...
But I was like, but...
I'm streaming.
I'm streaming today.
And then he was like...
And he was like, wow, you know, like, I can tell you have
it, you're grounded now.
And it's like, it's like you have a purpose.
And like, he's right.
Because like, I can stream now.
I have, okay, I actually, even though now it's a serious
note, that is my segue to the serious note thing.
But basically, I do have a, I have a purpose now.
I do.
I'm not playing video games until clicking 11 in the morning
anymore.
I actually have stuff I want to do again.
I actually have goals.
I actually have things I want to do.
Things I want to play.
Things I want to plan.
It's actually crazy.
The moment.
The moment I was finally free.
Like, I have so many ideas in my mind.
And I was so happy.
Okay, I was not so happy.
Okay, I cried.
I shouldn't say I was so happy.
I was like, I was happier than what I was a month ago.
That's for sure.
I was happier.
Anyway.
I was, I actually have a vision and everything.
So like, he wasn't wrong.
Like, instead of not knowing what my life was going to be,
at least now, I know where my life is going to be now so he
was right and then and then he was like so like how's your
channel i was like oh like i got 300 key subscribers in two
days he's like what the it was like what
I didn't...
Okay.
Yeah.
And he was like...
That's insane!
I was like...
Yeah.
But...
Um...
So...
It is actually...
Honestly...
It's...
What...
Looking forward...
In the future...
The future plans...
As Mia's doing.
is that I do have a lot of ideas going in oh my god okay so
you know how there's a business inquiries thing apparently
we got too many inquiries that Google thought I was a bot
so by the way I have a manager well I can't say manager song
because he's not Japanese he's he's American so it would be
weird to call him manager son um but um we made you know we
had like uh you know like the business inquiries there's
there's like you know the email dokey can read and then like
i got like a message be like hey like our emails are
bouncing so i'm gonna like dm you about this and i was like
what and then oh mr manager yeah mr manager no real that's
too many syllables what fuck are you that's too that's too
many syllables like it has to like like manage sorry i
forgot to count either like i never had um all i might i
just had to i was just playing video games like what do i
need counting for all right manager son okay has to be four
syllables mr manager that's five syllables that's way too
many syllables uh mr man okay mr man all right sorry mr man
um I was like, what the fuck's going on?
The emails are bouncing.
And he was like, oh, shit.
We have too many Google flagged the email account.
So, like, we're going to have to use my personal email.
That's just like, all right, this is a, all right, whatever.
This is not going to look professional, but at this point.
We need a business email going on there.
So I'm really, I'm really sorry.
about the business inquiries and you're like why is why are
the emails bouncing where is the reply um we're waiting for
google to like tell be like you're not a bot so so we're
gonna but for now we have mr man's personal email on my um
on the on the twitter profile right now so we're gonna do
with that anyway mr man has been how god us okay Anyway, Mr.
Man has been helping out a lot.
So, I talked about this in, if you were lucky in, if you
were lucky and you were in the chat whenever I popped by, I
gave like little tidbits of updates every so often.
When he told me, the thing is, I...
I was so, I guess like, oh, that's the right word.
What's the right word?
I was so, I guess, shocked.
I was like, and like, I don't know.
I don't know how to describe this feeling.
But, when he's like, what do you want to do?
And I was like, I want to do so many projects.
I want to host events.
on host events with so many different indies and different
companies in the West and everything and then and then Mr.
Mann was like uh uh what's did you okay I'm trying to like
phrase this better sorry I haven't talked this much in a
long time either like I don't I was not right I have not
talked in a long time And And then He was like We can get
sponsors for that I was like Huh?
And he was like Yeah, you don't have to pay out of your own
pocket anymore I was like What?
I was just like I was like Wait, huh?
That blew my mind That blew my mind By the way My mom
Scalded me about this Because You know, during all of this
during all of this um she looked at my financials and I made
zero profit last year because I spent it all it's just like
she was like so she had to spend less because because you
spent $200,000 last year and I and I I was like
that hurt oh that hurt but And then when Mr. Madden was
like, all those projects you want to do, all of that you
want to do, you don't have to, you won't be spending
$200,000.
I was so, it just blew my mind.
I, I blew my mind.
I couldn't, I couldn't believe it.
I, I couldn't believe those were my expenses last year.
I just, I just really like, I just really like projects.
I can't, I have a problem.
I have, I have a problem.
Oh my God.
Anyway.
Anyway, by the way, okay.
I want to say, leading up to that, I really do want to say
thank you everybody for the immense support throughout all
of this and so many, so many, oh my god, there's so many of
you, there's so many of you and so many, so many donations,
so many viewers and so many support from the so many
different people I just thank you I don't know I there's I
received a lot of messages a lot of like so many of my
friends from so like I made over like old friends new
friends reaching out and and giving their support and
everything it it really was I I cried so much I know I keep
saying that but like I I feel I felt like I I cried like at
least twice a day and but recently recently recently they
they have been happy tears and honestly like I I don't know
how much I can thank you guys and I really hope I can repay
all of you in the future for like everything you guys have
done and I was so surprised because like my friends over at
Apex and EA also they like you know like when I put up the
waiting room for the stream one of the Apex one of the Apex
staff members like messaged me and was like sending them
their support and was like saying was like screenshotting
the chat's waiting room and stuff and was just being so
supportive and everything and it was just oh my gosh I I
honestly I guide just everything I don't know.
I didn't expect really.
I felt like it was like, you know, end of the world.
It's hard to be hopeful after what happened, you know?
It's hard.
It's hard to be hopeful.
I honestly, but then, then I saw so many support and all the
love and all the messages I got throughout the past two days
and and I'm honestly I'm um I don't I'm just so overwhelmed
I've been so so overwhelmed um and I'll say thank you
everybody I I don't I I don't know what to do about you guys
I'm just a fucking stupid girl
I'm just it's crazy it really it really is and I I really
did feel very hopeless for for a while now and and just to
see all this love and being I guess like more positive about
my future now and also oh my god oh my it's just uh it's
hard to like put things in words i'm just i'm like
stammering and and pausing so much because it's really hard
to put words into the emotion like i feel right now and
really thank i know i keep saying thank you i keep saying
thank you i keep saying thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you but really thank you everyone i i really i'm
lining up a lot of collabs for next week um because i really
want to get back into swing of things and really I just I
wanna I really miss streaming I really really do when I
wasn't I wasn't online streaming during those long fucking
days oh my god during those it felt I was very miserable and
because I honestly I really do enjoy streaming I really
enjoy talking to all you guys I really enjoy doing it okay
what I found figured out is that I do not like playing video
games if I'm not like like single player okay I try to play
okay I I tried I try to play single player games with nobody
watching me But it was not the same It was It was not the
same And you know what I did I would drag my friends And uh
In like a Discord call And I'd be like Watch me play And
then we listen to me commentate
I was like Alright You're gonna pretend to be my chat and
I'm gonna be commentating while I play this game Oh my god,
okay, I saw someone said chat was like without the back.
Yes Oh my god, there was game I was playing and I literally
dragged one of my friends to watch me play this game So like
when we got to the puzzle parts, I would be like backseat me
I'm like
I'd be like, what's the answer?
It's backseating time.
So, um, I do miss that.
I actually, I really do miss the backseating.
I can't think for myself.
I can't.
But, like, oh my god.
Guys, I, what games do you guys?
Okay, but yes, I, I don't, okay, we're not going to have a
stream tomorrow because...
I think, okay, so I was just like, I need to stream But I
can't stream tomorrow, like, you know, when The fucking news
dropped I was like, do I stream tomorrow or The day after
tomorrow?
Because, you know, it was like Fucking five in the morning
So I was like Okay, we're gonna do the day After tomorrow
because I need to process all of this Because I'm not
processing anything So, so I was just like Alright I'm gonna
Day after tomorrow I'll stream My first stream And I'm just
I need to slowly get into it But next week Is gonna be Our
very first schedule Actuals I don't have a schedule template
I saw so many schedule templates Thank you so much For using
Doki Gallery Because I saw so many assets And everything And
thank you guys so much Um I need to find Schedule.
Accident.
I know there are schedule assets.
For those who made a schedule assets, can you guys make it
into like the square?
Because it fits into like...
I like it when it's not landscape.
But like, you know the square?
I don't know how to describe it.
You know, the square shape instead of the landscape.
It's not...
Was it full square?
I don't...
Guys, it's been so long.
I don't even remember what like, you know, back then looked
like.
I need to choose...
I'm trying to choose words carefully.
Because, like, I don't know what vocabulary it is anymore.
Portrait.
But it's not full portrait.
It's, like, somewhere.
I don't know.
You know, what it looks like.
When it looks nice on mobile type deal.
Like, I know there was a lot of landscape ones.
But, like, I would like the non-landscape.
Was it full portrait?
Size dimensions?
I don't remember.
Anyway.
Yes.
thank you see this is why I need a stream if I was by myself
I wouldn't have that like like this is exactly why people
need a stream like I'm not gonna think for myself I can
literally like mix I can like literally make someone else
think for me um and that's why it's a four by three there go
anyway um uh thank you guys so much i really really there's
so many there was so many beautiful artwork i when i when i
came back you know and just all the artists you know when i
said i loved art i've always supported artists i was back
then i was everywhere like not me but like me a lot I I
commissioned a lot of artists so because I love art I really
I really really I just love art and it I was you know
there's so many artists that drew me and I was I I was just
i was so emotional i was so emotional when all of you guys
started posting old artwork and old like old commissions
that that have you done over the years and then seeing them
being how i started their art career or like introduced them
to vtubing and stuff and like like oh like oh i you were
like the first person that ever commissioned me and stuff
like that and i thank you i i'm I'm just surprised you
remembered me.
Fun fact!
Those posters delete- I wish I didn't delete so- Oh my god.
I wish I didn't- I wish I didn't delete so much of my, like,
tweets and history.
Um...
Because I'm gonna fuck thought I was gonna be active here
again.
But, uh-huh.
Life has- life- life is unpredictable.
But, fun fact!
was one of ones that introduced Skeb to like a lot of people
on Twitter.
I had like a viral tweet about, because at that time, at
that time, no one really knew what that website was.
And I actually made a tweet about it and a guide on how to
use it.
Yeah, I actually, yeah, I actually, I was like, one, like,
the first people that, like, discovered it and, like,
tweeted out and stuff for everybody, um, to, like, introduce
it.
I deleted, okay, a lot, there's, like, at a certain year,
like, a lot of those tweets are, like, it, my, if you, like,
look through my tweet history now, it's, like, at this time,
it stops at a certain time of year, because, obviously,
Everything fucking down there is all gone now.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
And, uh, I remember, uh, I think I wasn't like, I was always
interested in like YouTubing and everything and, um, I
remember.
You know, I actually, uh, was one of the first, like, couple
of, like, one of the earliest, um, Iron Vertex, like,
customers back then.
Super early.
Super duper early.
Like, back when V-Tubing wasn't, like, like, super big yet,
and it is actually, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you might, I don't even know if you can, I'm pretty
sure you can still find, find like me on, on like one of
them, like, the, one of their portfolios, because I've
always been, like, super interested in it.
Anyway, for those who are wondering, for those who are
wondering, beneath this tomato form, this tomato will get a
new skin suit.
Not soon.
not soon because art takes a long time sorry sorry skin suit
designing you know because it's real skin and real hair uh
sorry immersion uh that um is i don't know the skin suit is
honestly it's it's it's three three plus years okay It's not
just three.
It's like almost Four years old.
It's four years old And this tomato Has not washed the skin
soon a long time For it lived in the dumpster While it was
gone.
And now I'm back here.
Right now I'm back here.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway, information time.
Information time.
Anyway, because obviously You know, what is two Days of work
got me We'll have two days of stuff I did on this stream.
Here is the slide, i.e.
the text.
All right, birthday.
Birthday.
Yes.
Oh, my gosh.
Shift does that.
Sorry.
I don't know my bindings.
All right, birthday.
So I might, like, my face malfunction sometimes.
So...
birthday oh my god Doki you actually Doki your birthday is
actually July 4th yes
alright anyway July 4th the most non the most American
Canadian out there my birthday is actually yes July 4th oh
my god I know alright speaking of like Canadian I said this
in chat when this all happened but basically obviously my
DMs are you know open so which isn't oh my gosh I shouldn't
have said that because now people are gonna be like oh my
god we're gonna fucking message Doki on her on the DMs
there's so many I'll just let you guys know I'll be closing
them very soon it's just a little adjustment period because
like you know our our my Mr. Man's email address is not
doing so well right now so but obviously throughout all of
this that happened that happened obviously you know i'd get
some pretty pretty weird dms and one of them there was a lot
going on but one one of them it was entertainment at that
point because like it just got funnier and funnier as it
went on uh but basically uh they were like you live in
canada and i like as if it's like a dox so
like you're like i got you you're a canadian and i'm like
okay so
like as as a threat so i was just i i I was, I, I, I don't
know.
I, I, I, I, I was just like, you know, at that point, you
sort of feel a bit sorry.
Because, like, what goes in your mind being like, oh my God,
I got it.
She lives in the second largest, largest country in the
world.
I got her.
Like, oh my God, I'll know exactly where she is now.
uh also i'll give like a little help too i'm on the west
coast if that helps out that sounds so oh also um regarding
um other things um i will mr man is working on opening a po
box for for um everybody and i'm hoping for the po box you
guys can send in uh you guys can send like you know no food
um because that's always fucking sketchy i don't that's
that's always fucking sketchy um there's gonna be guidelines
that's mr man's job not my job um but there's gonna be uh
you can send in like you know bad merch if you want to or
like fan mail and um um gifts and stuff and he's gonna vet
it and then send it back to me so um don't write anything
too weird because he's gonna read all of it he's gonna read
it unless you want to send mr man some fan mail and i don't
know maybe he's into like whatever freaky shit you want to
send him um but like uh he's gonna be reading all the fan
mail to make sure you know i'll know like it'd be fucked up
if you just send me some hate mail like i've you know i've
already been through a lot so i don't think um i'm literally
going to therapy so i don't really want to go to my
therapist next week and be like so yeah my manager sent me
hate mail um i don't really know what that means in general
or like what he really thinks about me so
so uh so yes anyway i like how all i wrote was birthday i i
actually had like other stuff i want okay give me a sec i
wrote all of this down i was like here is the plan dokey
here is the plan on like where you're supposed to go with
all of this which is okay I just want you guys to know plan
what I wrote for the plan is birthday doxy story doky doge
tags that's the that's the where it's leading to anyway um
doky doge doky doge Which came first?
Of course I love my...
Well...
Now I love myself again.
We gotta be realistic here.
I love myself again.
So...
But back then...
I really loved myself.
So...
When I got Doki Doge...
I named him after me.
So...
...
But then, it might get a little confusing.
So, because, you know, Doki, Doki Doge, it might get a
little bit confusing.
Also, there's like, it's just too many Ds.
So, we might give him a little nickname just to distinguish
between Doki 1 and Doki 2.
And I'm very willing to let you guys decide what...
Do-Kidoge's nickname is.
So you guys can decide.
Do-Kidoge nickname.
Guys.
You guys can decide.
Oh my god.
Don't be so.
Guys.
I'm trying to like.
You guys can decide.
Do-Kidoge nickname.
That I'll be using.
On stream.
Just so we can distinguish.
Which.
Doki 1 and Doki 2.
Oh my god!
Amused Glacier!
What a great suggestion.
Through random picking.
sheer randomness and random picking.
I feel like, I don't know, I feel like, for some reason, we
could call him Doki Ember Doge Oh no Thank you Glacier I
just closed my eyes and like Picked one name on random But
like it's spelled with an A Just so you guys know It's Doki
Ember Doge What's this?
Oh sorry that's Twitch alert Because I haven't set up
YouTube alerts yet I haven't
So you can called doki doge amber if you like also like it
helps out because i don't really don't want to say doki doge
or doki a lot so his middle name is now uh doki amber doge
amber for sure so and he and i feel like he's like super
used to it anyway at this point
um anyway this is how scuffed it was i didn't even but i
didn't even set up like youtube alerts because i was like
i'm not even monetized so i'll just set up twitch alerts
like i mean i had twitch alerts so i was just like just
whenever i got monetized i'll figure that stuff out later um
yay tags i really i was i don't know the only one i have so
far Doki Gallery, I didn't want to put art on there because,
I don't know, by, for some reason, I realized, I don't know,
from research, I guess, that when you put art in any art
tag, like the word art in there, it, um, oh my god, dad.
um it gives you like you know a lot of like nfts and and
bots so by sheer research and i don't know maybe wow maybe
some like it came to me in a dream i realized that i'm never
using art for an art tag ever again so so our our uh our our
art tag is jokie gallery uh we're gonna have i guess like
tag suggestion you know what we're just gonna do it to the
point because we're retiring this tag anyway but any for any
tag suggestions and names feel oh my gosh feels i might make
some funny faces while i'm typing just so you guys know um
oh my god dad sorry
tag suggestions all right tag suggestions um let's see i
don't know hashtag dokey tag suggestions
all right if you want to suggest tags it is hashtag dokey
tags tag suggestions there we go so like you know uh like
the usual tags i guess like live tag memes tag um i forgot
i'm sorry it's please give me it's been a month plus it's
actually it's been so long
this this is so long i i was like fuck what what do we use
for tags again.
I just remembered the live tag, the memes tag, the, oh,
shrine!
Yes!
We're bringing back the shrine.
Oh, doki shrine.
I'm just gonna, this is to the point.
I swear to God, if someone already has doki.
I, this is the worst part because it's like, doki is like,
it's like a real word, so it's like, it's like a real word.
So I feel like someone already at use, guys, don't use doki
that doki stride is a natural real tag because it makes
sense when you put it together so
so give a shrine tag somewhere um uh oh where was i where
was i where was i where was i uh fuck okay uh
My brain is like on cogwheels right now Trying to get back
into the groove of things Because it's like I had a system
of everything Oh wait no I already finished everything I
want to say Right I had I really The order of this The
chronological order of this Was Birthday Doxing story Dokey
Doge Dokey Amber Doge Tags Oh merch merch I don't know if
Mr. Man has like finished setting okay to get started on
your dokey shrine we're relaunching relaunching the original
the original dokey merch um please applaud Mr. man because
two hours before the stream I was like okay um can you like
put these things up on the store I'll give you the
information and illustration just put it all up there I
don't have time
so um um let me check real quick if the store is up yet uh
let's see oh Oh, please no, wait.
Oh, that was when I asked him.
That's when he talked about, like, reading, like, getting
Fatmail directed at him.
And he's like, I don't really want to read.
I don't really want to read the freaky ones directed at me.
All right, all right.
Mr. Mad, are you, do you have the story link?
If not, it's okay.
We can segue into something else.
Also, also, also, also, also, also, also, also.
We will have a Lunar New Year stream Because as someone
that, you know, I celebrate Lunar New Year, you know, due to
my culture.
And the holiday really does mean a lot to me.
It really does mean a lot to me.
And it's the year of, you know, of new beginnings.
So, I was going to save this on Lunar New Year, but then I
was just like, I just want to spoil you guys a little bit.
So, we will be having Lunar New Year merch, which will come
out on Lunar New Year.
And...
This will be...
This will be the acrylic stand for...
It's not finished yet.
It's still a draft.
But this is one of the Lunar New Year merch that I'm going
to be selling.
And there's one more.
I'm really, really, really excited about this one I'm super
happy about.
This is a little preview.
But I will have some Red Pocket Evolopes!
It's a little preview!
Oh my god!
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh.
When you see the full illustrations, it's like actually...
I'm...
I cannot wait, but we're gonna have Red Pocket Envelopes,
too.
This is, obviously, it's just a little preview, so when, you
know, during Lunar New Year, when, you know, whoa, you get
to see the whole thing!
Whoa!
But we're gonna have a three-pack of some Lunar New Year
envelopes.
So, you can use it to...
Honestly, like, honestly, the best advice is to, like, never
get married.
So, you can always receive Red Pocket Envelopes.
So, honestly, just keep it for display, Because why the fuck
would you want to give money to little kids?
Like...
Because I was a little kid back then, too.
And I was a little kid back then, too.
And I abused the shit of the Lunar New Year system.
As in, I would go and hang out at my grandpa's place.
Because he was the head of the family.
In Lunar New Year.
In China.
You have to go to the head of the family.
Like place.
And pay your respect.
So I would stay there overnight.
I would stay there overnight.
And because.
I was the first.
Granddaughter.
Um.
That.
has the that was my dad like you know because you know my
dad's a man so
so i have his last name mr bird
i'd get more money and and that's how you cheese the system
make sure go to make sure you go to the head of the family's
place stay overnight never get married so you can get more
money and never have to give away money there you go just be
born and be born first no no no no born first but for your
dad's side and that's how you do it as long as as long as
you do that he has so much money you got so much money and
go to every family dinner make sure you go to every single
family dinner because sometimes they forgot they gave you
this gave you an envelope already so sometimes they forget
to give you an envelope already so they give it to you again
because they give so many envelopes they actually forget um
and then you have to make sure If you are the firstborn,
firstborn grandchildren, make sure you tell them that
because they'll be like, oh my god, that's Toki.
That's Mr. Bird.
That's Grandpa Bird's firstborn grand-granddaughter.
We gotta give her the bigger ones.
Genius!
But Toki, what if I'm not the firstborn?
firstborn you will be soon because they'll have to get
married if you never get married one day you will become
then you move up if you never get married the the firstborn
would have to get married so you become the firstborn so
their firstborn money will go to you there you go and That's
why you should never get married If you celebrate Lunar New
Year Because I don't know, some people might have been like
But Doki, I don't celebrate Lunar New Year I was gonna say
like That just sucks for you At that point, I don't know
Sorry, I don't know Like if you don't celebrate Lunar New
Year at that point I don't know I don't know that just well
just sucks to you i guess uh stop leaking the strategy how
many firstborns are out there this is only reserved to
firstborn children only who are not married
all right sorry that was a weird i haven't guys i haven't
tangent in so long it's actually been so long since I've
tangent.
It's so weird.
I haven't talked this long in a... I... Oh my gosh.
I haven't talked this long in a while.
Oh yes.
What are you guys?
You're... I don't really want you guys to be Bark Nights.
Because, um...
To be honest, uh... I feel like the Bark Nights are the
past.
Well, past, past.
Current.
This is current now.
I know it's a bit mind-fucking.
But this past current life.
I guess that's how you explain it.
I feel like we've grown.
As a person.
I'm a person now.
I actually can say I'm a tomato.
How we grown.
The skin suit.
I'm a person now.
Whoa.
She takes off her hat.
She has some animal character.
We'll never know.
We'll never know what's under this hat.
um so i honestly i don't know um anyone like suggest what
you guys want to be called uh and honestly we can just
decide and chat right now what you guys want to be called um
because i really i i don't want you guys to be bark knights
and i don't know what you guys are is it great oh yeah What
are you, though, Doki?
Well, I don't know if you guys heard of an evolution, but,
like, I'm a bird now.
Whoa, so clever.
As if, like, 200,000 people didn't make the same joke, and I
just stole it off chat.
Uh, because, uh, this thief never steals.
Um, free birds.
Okay.
It just doesn't make sense.
Free birds.
I know you guys want to be caught up, but like, if I use
that in a sentence, that's the hardest part, because you're
like, you want it to be usable in the sentence as well.
So, like, Free Birds isn't, like, the best way to say stuff.
So, like, I actually don't even know what you guys are.
different designs too we'll figure that out we'll have a
we'll have a we'll have like a fan mascot stream in the
future whenever I figure out my schedule and everything so
don't worry guys we're gonna have a fan mascot a fan mascot
stream where we draw the fan mascot in the next time um but
for now I do really would like to I do really want to decide
a name for all of you Because I don't know.
I don't fucking know what to call you.
We need some material to work with.
I'm sorry.
I found out two days ago.
I can use that joke because I'm the depressed one here.
Like, you just got...
I've been through so much at this point.
It's all about laughing it off at that point.
Because, like, if I stop and think and realize the reality,
of everything I it will not be great for me so we have to we
still have to laugh it off sometimes um the i'm not calling
you guys the fucking flock the raft don't the fuck you guys
a basketball team No, absolutely not.
Look, I'm not going to have fucking little tomatoes running
around.
Not have that.
Tomatoes are for...
Tiny tomatoes are for eating.
Big tomatoes are for eating little tiny tomatoes.
We're not...
I'm not calling you guys the nuggets.
What are these names?
I came back for you guys to backseat me better.
Yes, it's supposed to be better backseaters
I like how someone's That's a hockey team
Alright guys Alright Apparently Apparently Right now Why
must you hate all our ideas?
Why must you hate all our ideas?
Well I don't even know this this but
it's not that I hate all your ideas but your ideas are
pretty fucking terrible look I get it I get it it's been a
while it's been a while you guys gotta get all the terrible
ideas out first before we hit the good ones so like I get it
you haven't let them out yet in the long time you know you
haven't said all these you've been keeping all these
terrible ideas in you for so long.
So, like, eventually, you know, you get all that out of your
system and fall into the routines.
Good ideas will start coming out.
The Okie doke.
Oh my are we, like, what, in kindergarten?
Hello, little Okie-Dokies.
Are you ready to learn the alphabets?
Little Okie-Dokie.
No.
The...
wingman hello wingman no no absolutely not absolutely not
we're not no wingman okay all right i feel like i feel like
all of us are having trouble here so it's moving on moving
on use the dokey tag suggestions use the dokey tag
suggestion to figure out, you know, you know, what you want
to be called.
What you want to be called.
Because at the moment...
I like how it's like...
I like how there's literally two...
I think I didn't make a PowerPoint slide because these are
the two things I really...
Like, likes and dislikes!
I don't...
At this point, I feel like we all...
To be fair, who the fuck watches...
Back to watch just for the likes and dislikes.
Like, I'm gonna say it.
I'm gonna say it.
Like...
Who the fuck actually...
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Oh, wait, that's fine.
I'm not even monetized.
Oh, shit.
That scared the shit out of me.
Oh, my God.
Um, where the fuck is the ad?
There we go.
I, I honestly, I'm just, even though I'm not monetized, I
only don't want this thing getting, like, this song is
blocked in these countries.
Because that would fucking suck.
That would actually, like, suck.
Where was I?
Wait, what was I talking about before I got...
before.
Fuck, what was I talking about?
God damn it.
Now I have free birds stuck in my head.
We're not gonna be called free birds!
It doesn't...
I know you guys... Holy shit Lord Pancake!
I'm so sorry like if you all...
Thank you so much for the donation.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm gonna say it.
Like I don't look back to a YouTuber debut.
Honestly, it's not even a debut.
I'm just back.
Like to be like, Wait, I have my debut stream still.
That's right.
I'm not making it because why did I put my birthday?
You can literally look at the debut stream that's still on
this channel from four years ago.
It's still there.
I can't believe I forgot I've debuted before.
and I'm holy shit guys I've actually debuted before so you
can look at the debut pod for likes and dislikes why did I
even put birthday alright anyway oh but the tags back there
they're like retired um because it's new me new me new life
I like how people are still like what about free bird we're
not gonna be free bird the reason why we're not gonna be
free birds is that it doesn't It doesn't, like, roll off the
tongue as good as you guys think it does.
It doesn't.
Also, also, um...
Like, how do you...
How the fuck do you visualize that?
Like...
It's harder for all of us to, like, think of, like, what y
'all look like if you're called Free Bird.
So don't...
where we'll figure that out.
We'll figure that out soon.
Um, but, oh my god.
Oh, it's actually, it's, uh, it's actually, it's just been
wild.
I, I feel like I haven't, I feel like I'm losing stamina
because like, I haven't talked this long in a very long
time.
I'm so I'm just I'm not used to it but I also I I miss it so
much I really do I I really I really miss this a lot and I
really just I miss just talking with all of you and and just
I guess like restarting and and oh god there's just so much
potential and let's try let's try and aim for 500k
subscribers by the end of this year okay guys you guys think
we can do it I think that's I think like goals wise I would
love to hit 500 alright goals oh my god goals almost forgot
I think it'll be 500k subscribers by the end of this year
and then my dream goal would be a million subscribers and um
i i guess like the pc uh a pc sponsor and a gaming gear
sponsor oh my gosh i would love to have a gaming gear
sponsor i want i want i want to you know like there's like
you know like because okay I love when people are like why
the fuck do you have two mouse pads you don't fucking
understand alright for all you non-gamers out there you have
a normal desk mat that's like cute or I don't know like
anime like JJK on there or some shit I don't know usually
it's either something fucking cute or like the anime of the
year which would be I guess like JK.
And then on top of it, you have a second mouse pad on top of
it.
And it's the gamer mouse pad.
So it's like, I use the, what the fuck do I use?
I think I use the hand effects.
I can't read.
It's been used a while.
So I use the hand effects, but there's like Skypad and stuff
like that.
Like if you want to use glass, like mouse pad, there's like
Skypad.
And I would love to have any gaming gear.
I should write this down, but like, you guys can write it
down.
for me um but honestly that would be the dream come true for
me as well it's crazy i so so many people reached out to me
for to like for like sponsors and like deals and all that
stuff and I'm not used to it at all You know, I've always
thought I wasn't marketable
And so I I have a huge imposter I've always had a huge
imposter syndrome And I've Oh my god Like The stuff that Mr.
Man Like sent to me uh it i was just i i was like what
they're like oh yeah this this and then you won't do this
and i was like huh huh i'm what and i i just never i don't
know it's just crazy it really
and I'm getting emotional I told myself I shouldn't cry
because I've cried too much I really have cried way way too
fucking much and it's just I I was so surprised I never died
I you know people would want me to advertise their stuff but
I was just this anime girl that played video games and Okay,
maybe not sometimes.
Maybe apparently not sometimes.
It's nice to laugh, though.
It's nice to laugh again.
It really is.
I don't think I've laughed.
I haven't laughed this much in a while now.
And it's nice to be happy for this moment.
And I want to say thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Uh, I like how I say everybody because you guys have no name
yet, but...
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
It really, it really is.
Just thank you for making me laugh again, and I hope I can
make you guys laugh again as well.
I miss laughing with all of you, and oh my gosh.
what we can finally do?
A member's Minecraft server, but I can't stream it in
members.
I can finally, I can finally do it!
I advise Minecraft server!
But I can't stream it in members, though.
My crystal, they're still...
Even though, even though I'm like, well, still can't do
everything.
Ed Garfield Cart They can't say no if I never asked
That's America Because North America Fair use laws Let's
fucking go What's that word called?
Where if you have enough Like you can put enough of your
commentary Fuck there's a word Is this a word?
It's no fair use, where you put enough of your commentary,
like, it's like your work.
Like...
Oh my god.
The best part.
Freddy Fish!
Can't say no!
Creative Commons!
I'm gonna say America.
I'm like I told you the most American Canadian out there.
Transformative!
This is transformative work.
Alright, sorry.
The first joke was like, oh my, let me ask for it.
Oh, we don't have to anymore.
Oh my god.
But...
I'm an indie.
I have transformative work Oh, all right, anyway, for those
who are wondering Platforms Oh my god, itchigo games And
like, you know, like I really always wanted to just find
random games on Steam And just be like Anyway, uh, what's I
gonna say?
Fuck, okay Shit, okay, wait, wait, I had something.
I had something right there.
God damn it, never mind, I forgot.
I forgot, I actually forgot what I was gonna say.
Okay, but yes, one of my first streams I really want to do
was... Did you guys know there's private Neopets server?
Oh my god, I was talking to Gumi, you know, Gumi, one of my
best friends for like seven fucking plus years.
I was talking to Gumi, and like, she's like, bitch, why the
fuck are you talking about Neopets?
And I was just like that's gonna be my that's gonna be my
first gaming stream and she was like oh my god check out my
private server neopets account and that blew my fucking mind
there's private server neopets account like and she was like
yeah inflation fucking sucks on the rig on the public
servers I was like what it's like it got so bad that people
had to make private servers because the inflation fucking
sucks like that blew my fucking mind I was like excuse me I
can finally do it I can finally stream meal pets oh my god
they brought back unconverted pets do you guys know that fun
fact um the unconverted pets are on the black market where
you actually have to pay pay real money like thousands of
dollars to own an unconverted pet and now the market fucking
crashed because now they're introducing it back because um
the creators of all right okay i can say this now because
like i'm i don't have to like tiptoe to lie but if you guys
didn't know neopets used to be owned by scientology i can
say that now like i don't okay but but they sold They sold
it.
And then they try to be an NFT game.
And then they sold it to someone else.
And...
And now...
Now it's bought back by...
Apparently the CEO of Neopets now is actually like...
Some nostalgic old Neopets player.
He's like some fucking guy that grew up on Neopets who's
like some tech Mongol now.
and he like bought back Neo pets and he's like bring back
unconverted pets which I think it's because you know he's
like I have so much money now I will I don't want to you
know what you have like a lot of money and then you're just
like give me back what the original version was so I can
live my childhood now that type of deal we have so much
money you buy back something and just revert it back to what
it was because that's where you had found happiness So,
like, that's what he did.
And now, the Allen Converted Pets are back now.
So, like, he literally brought back, like, nostalgia just
for himself.
All right, so, like, what I want to do on Neo Pets is I want
to enter the beauty contest because I want to fucking
actually win first place in a beauty contest with the least
amount of effort and Neopets taught me the hard thing like
taught me fucking harsh reality where it's not about how
good you are at art it's basically a fucking popularity
contest and who to fuck advertise like and who advertises on
the beauty contest forums the most and all that I'll vote
for you shit if you vote for me now now I'm a streamer so I
can abuse
now I can I can make you vote for me I don't didn't fucking
work for that anymore so Roblox someone said it I can
finally do warrior cats roleplay no you don't understand
warrior cats roleplay has been thing I wanted to stream for
fucking ever.
No!
Okay.
I know like, okay, for those who never grew up with warrior
cats, all right, now you read, okay, when you get older, you
realize this, the books were pretty fucked up.
Um, because like, it was written by three different women.
Like I said, girls.
Uh, it was written by three different women.
And like, there were so many fucking cats that like, they
didn't even know what the fuck was going on anymore.
Because
One book was made by three different women That it was so
hard to remember what cat was what Because I felt like
they're always making babies So like there's always new
fucking cats So there's like a whole fucking Wikipedia
Trying to figure out which cat is what Because there's so
many There's like Ravenpaw 1 and Ravenpaw 2 Ravenpaw 1 from
Fire Clan And then Ravenpaw fucking 500 and Shadow Clan and
shit like that And you don't care just three cats or some
shit like Firestar fucking something anyway sorry I sorry I
got I got way too in it yeah Aaron Hunter is not one person
it's three it's 30 that blew my fucking mind and they they
always forget what cat was what like if you it's like a
thing they're like who the fuck is like shadow pelt or
whatever like was was he the one that like I don't know was
he the one that Fuck that cat?
Oh, we don't know.
Oh, he has two dads now.
All right.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to...
I haven't had shit in so...
I...
I watched so many shorts.
I watched so many YouTube shorts.
I've gained so many knowledge on YouTube shorts.
That I...
Like, while watching YouTube shorts, like, fun fact, like,
there's, like, you know, some YouTube shorts have...
like fun facts and shit like that i've like liked so many
shorts so like i was like whatever if i could ever stream
again i need to i need to tell them the things i learned all
the things i learned on the fucking internet i need it i
need to tell somebody and there's so many much i i swear i
like wasted like three to four hours of my life just in my
bed just watching youtube shorts because life was
meaningless back then koki why are you laughing that sounded
so fucking depressing because if you don't laugh it gets too
real
Okay.
Ah, fuck, okay.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
Wait.
Mr. Man, is the store ready?
Mr. Man!
Is the store ready?
If the store is ready, just send me the link, Mr. Man.
I don't even know if my manager is even watching me, to be
honest.
I don't know.
oh my god first day on the job well not it wasn't his first
day on the job but guys i have to message mr man right now
all right it's the store ready whoop there i go it's the
shift key for those who are wondering why i keep doing that
why why the fuck do i keep moving like this all right boop
there we go wait what no no that's not how I oh my gosh boop
there we go there we go sorry so wait not even aligned fuck
okay
oh I am such a mess I am I'm such a fucking mess this but
i'm your mess what does it say about you guys for watching
this oh just feels so good to stream again i i oh my god it
really really it feels so good to stream again i i really
miss this i really i really miss this okay because i know mr
man isn't watching me he was like did you look at the
preview of the store and i said yes but i actually didn't
but it's okay he doesn't know because he's not even watching
me so my first test does my manager even watch my first
fucking stream
That's my very first test.
He doesn't know.
Oh, I don't.
I think he's.
Uh.
I don't.
Wait.
He's typing.
He's the first one in the wild.
Mr. Men.
Are you even watching my very first stream where I literally
said I didn't even check the preview.
And I said yes.
anyway
wait no no wait wait wait okay okay wait wait wait a minute
no he's not by the way I don't think he's watching because I
fucking I can say whatever the fuck I want to this guy and
he doesn't know
there you alright because he was like do you want a store to
be in Canadian Canadian Canadian dollars I also I was like,
fuck, you know, the Canadian dollar sucks.
Why the fuck do I want to be Canadian dollar?
Why would Canadians relate, though?
Canadians relate.
We'd rather have American money.
Well, I'd rather have American money and then, like, you
know, fucking, even if we convert it back to Canadian money,
it's still a lot more money than Canadian.
not wrong give me that sweet old american cash not canadian
cash uh oh yeah we put 90 for free fucking new video games
that's the best part oh my god you can't no i hate you
should all right uh uh basically uh i wasn't gonna say what
i was gonna say fuck sorry it's been so long for me to talk
that like whenever i have something on my mind it like
disappears so fast now because like i'm so nice it's like
not a routine anymore so it's So, I was like, yeah, idea.
And then, and then my idea just, it's just no idea.
No, no idea anymore.
Oh my God.
I'm so fucking washed.
I'm so washed.
I like how people are still suggesting bad names.
They're like, okay.
Yeah, you say that.
Anyway, what about Free Bird?
Guys We're not We're not gonna be free Oh my god, okay So
you know how I watched You know how I watched Twilight With
my friend And I was like What the fuck are you watching
twilight and she was like no you don't understand it's so
good it's like bad good and then okay okay so i need i need
to talk about this i need to talk about this so the thing is
like so like collins family all right the whole story is
like I didn't realize how the cinematography is honestly
what the fuck was cinematography but like the Collins
everyone is fucking their own sibling sorry banging their
own I don't need to worry about that anyway banging their
own sibling like adopted sibling except for Edward and like
and like but then they're like the cool popular kids I was
like I swear to God why the fuck you think like
you're like oh my god she's so cool she pink her boyfriend
is her adopted brother it's so fucking cool i'm like what
the what and and the thing is like you know how the book is
written by a a mormon so like um so like for her it's like
you know whoa only after marriage you know like it's like so
like because you know he was like no only when we're married
you know so like i'm thinking because edward's a hundred and
something years old right so he's like a hundred years and
then i realized i said this i like Said it out loud
afterwards.
I was like, oh my god Ever it's a fucking hundred-year-old
version.
I was like, oh my god, and then like my friend I was just
like so shocked I said that because it didn't click in her
head It didn't click in her head because you know, he's
never married
He's a super wizard.
I was like, and then I...
But then, like, the thing is, like, one of his adopted
sibling was, like, was like, I don't like Bella.
Like, I don't like Bella.
I don't want her, like, near us.
She's a human.
But, like, I was like, bro.
bro he's let him have something you have your fucking
adopted brother he has nothing for a hundred years I was
like bro she's like no I want him to be single forever I was
like that's so fucked up anyway also there's wolf puberty
too for those who don't know wolf okay so for the context
for wolf puberty it's that um the context of wolf puberty is
that so there's a wolf tribe and like when you hit wolf
puberty you like beef the fuck up so like before before you
hit wolf puberty you're like this fucking scrawny kid i read
the first book of twilight for those at that time in my
volleyball team.
And then everyone in my volleyball team read Twilight.
And then they were always like, are you Team Edward or Team
Jacob?
So I wanted to fit in because they would be on a fucking
like doggy pile reading Twilight and shit like that.
So then I was like, oh shit, okay, I need to fit in with
these girls.
So I guess I'll read Twilight.
After I read like up to two books.
And then after that, I still buy the book so I can bring it
to practice.
But like when the book comes when the newest book comes out
I would go to like the Twilight Wikipedia and just read the
wiki But I'll pretend to bring I'll bring the book to
pretend that I read it So then they'll like ask me about the
plot and then I just be like I'll just fucking I'll just
remember the shit I read on Wikipedia so I didn't have to
read the book
Because I'm sorry but it was so bad
I just cliff note that shit because like anyway in the book
Jacob is like some fucking scrawny ass teenager or some shit
but then he hits wolf puberty puberty and he starts taking
off shirt and like gets like buffer the thing is the actor
that plays Jacob Taylor Taylor and Loner by the way he
marries his wife is also called Taylor Loner and consider
Taylor and Taylor um I don't fucking know I'm not I don't
know what the fuck is going on with that scenario I don't
know That's like a fucking fetish or something.
But like, it has to be.
Like, I feel like it just has to be.
Like, why the fuck would you...
Oh my god.
Who are you?
Taylor Laundry?
You're...
Oh my god.
What a coincidence.
Now I love you.
Anyway.
Um.
But like in the movies, Jacob.
Jacob is like...
He looks...
He didn't get skinnier.
For the role.
They just put more clothes on him.
So he...
like you can tell you can tell like he didn't want to force
him to like bulk up for the second movie so like you can
tell that they're like how the fuck do we make him look like
like a scrawny ass stick let's just put like 500 layers of
clothes on him and give him long hair to hide his like
fucking muscle or some shit and then like when he hits wolf
puberty let's just give make him shirtless and cut his hair
so it looks like he hit wolf puberty so that's a little fun
fact wanted also uh yes i'll confirm that she was like here
comes the next best part and then she literally was like
spider monkey i was just like what the fuck
watched um we also like um uh watched live action pinocchio
i was like uh i told her i was like oh no you don't
understand like the live action disney movies are a are
something and she's never really watched live action disney
movies so like oh my god I live action Pinocchio okay, you
know how like the reviews for live action Pinocchio like
It's like fucking I don't know like 20% or some shit I don't
I can't I don't really know the numbers on top of my head
But then you're like it can't be that bad like how how can
you fuck up?
There's Tom Hanks is in there like how how does that work
literally Tom Hanks is in there and um the thing is uh it it
we we like watched i think 15 minutes of live action
pinocchio and we're like all right let's pop in real
pinocchio like this it's i it's it's oh my god it is Tom
Hanks cannot save that fucking movie like we we only kept
watching for the fox because we wanted because like I was
like no the fox the the 3D no you don't understand the 3D
animation for the fox for some fucking reason they cut 90%
of the budget for the main character Pinocchio and then put
it all on the fucking fox because why the fuck does he the
fox look like that and then you look at Pinocchio The Fox is
on like 600 frames per second and Pinocchio is like, I don't
know Fox is like 4080 RTX on Pinocchio is like flash games
and I don't understand
Like that that that is the the That is the craziest part of
all of that All right, I'm gonna ask for I'm gonna ask for
the fucking for the fucking store update real quick How how
is the store update?
I swear to God I I don't understand Minuki is the main
character.
I don't understand Anyway, that's what I was saying uh What
are my plans for next week?
I definitely want to do like...
I definitely want to play Neo Pets for the first gaming
stream.
And then I want to line up a bunch of collabs going in.
And I feel like a lot of you guys might have this question.
Meaning like...
Oh!
What are some of your events you want to plan?
One of the events I really, really, really want to do...
Is a big...
A big...
wrestling event with a lot of different indies and and
vtuber companies in na i think it'll be really fun i think
it'll be really fun and um i really want to order i really
want to order uh some enamel pins to give out to everybody
who participates as well it'll be i think that that's
definitely some future plans that i really want to do some
projects that i really want to I really want to organize
some mini, some tournaments like for different games and
stuff.
And with prizes and everything and trophies and physical
trophies.
I think it'll be really fun.
I think like the most fun events are the ones that you can
be super creative about.
Have like something to cheer on for Yeah, that's like some
of the projects and events I really want to I really want to
plan out In a call give me five No, Mr. Okay, I'm gonna
Leave that call
I wonder if you can fix up I wonder if Mr. Man would take
that seriously or not.
He's not even watching the first stream anyway.
He doesn't fucking know if I'm serious or not.
Open store.
Okay, I'll just write JK.
I want to do escape rooms.
I want to do like Minecraft escape rooms and like pit people
against each other.
That shit would be so fun.
And then you'd be like, oh my god, which.
Which, like, and then you guys can, like, cheer on for,
like, which team of our team and stuff like that.
That would be so fucking fun.
I feel like there's not a lot of, like, um, like, there's a
lot of, like, MCC for, like, Minecraft content creators.
But you don't see, like, a lot of MCC for, like, VTubers as
well.
So I want to do, like, a VTuber MCC.
and stuff with like mini games and everything because like
oh my god I can do so many things I can do so many plans and
projects and league games
obviously Apex of course of course I actually do have like
an Apex tournament that I'm working on with some best some
besties so that's something to look forward to as well um
that's right we're still the besties we're still there we're
still there um and honestly like i said there's so many
ideas and um i'm really excited to plan all of that with,
uh, with my manager.
And I cannot wait.
I really cannot wait.
I cannot wait.
I cannot wait to get started.
I, I'm so excited, honestly.
Uh, oh yeah, for those who don't know what MCC is, it's like
the Minecraft championship, but usually it's like something
you see for Minecrafters, like Minecraft content creators.
But honestly, I haven't seen one of those.
I really want to do like, I feel like a lot of tournaments
and a lot of events, they're like always one company and
stuff.
I think it'd be really fun to have like in a company wide.
Oh, like team Indies and like and like like different
companies and NA participating and stuff and like fan bases
from different areas like watching.
I think that would be really fun.
I really think, because you always see like tournaments
events usually from one company.
But I think it'd be really cool to have like uh to set
something up where people from different companies can
participate and stuff so yeah i want to do something like
that all right okay okay i see it powworld i'm gonna say it
after you play like three days of powworld's non-stop like
you it's that's it like
i'm gonna Fucking say it You realize it's it's a fun.
It's fun, but like when you hit three day needs the power
You hit a point where you're like all right.
Yeah, I realize after three days it's like the same thing
It's like
And like honestly like it just needs like more It needs more
updates to keep me interested.
But, like, the thing about Palworld, the thing about
Palworld is that, like, it is very fun.
It's a very fun unique concept, and, honestly, like, that's
what we need.
Like, I wish we had that in other similar...
Wait, I can say it now.
In Pokemon!
Sorry, my inner filter.
fucking kicked in
because I liked like the ones that Pokemon Legends Arceus or
whatever that was that was that was that one I really liked
that one I really really liked that game and I wish I wish I
wish Pokemon can be similar as well the fucking Mr. Man I
cannot stall Mr. Man Wait, why did I type Mr. Man?
I know, like, I cannot stall anymore.
Um.
Give me a story.
But yeah, I think, like, streaming is a great it's just when
you start streaming i don't know streaming always makes me a
lot happier and when i couldn't stream i felt so empty oh my
god i felt i i was i've been in a routine for so long that
when when you know when you suddenly stop streaming it it's
just it's like what do i do with my life at that point
because you've been in this routine for you so so fucking
long and it just makes me so happy being able to just stream
and laugh with you guys and talk about the dumbest fucking
thing
just have fucking people enable the shit out of me and
everything and i think like my therapist was right when he
was like oh like you seem very different now after like
compared to the other times oh my god man the other times
i'm fucking oh man oh it was like yeah you seem very very
different and you actually seem like you you have a purpose
in life again and he's right he's right i felt like i have a
purpose and i have i'm very goal oriented person and being a
very goal oriented person um i always like to plan the next
thing to do something and everything to always to always
just i just always want to do something i always want to
keep my mind um busy so it's nice because my mind has been
like chugga chugga chug for for the last two days and
honestly i it's nice to be busy again it's nice to have
stuff to do i really do need to fix my sleep schedule though
holy shit my sleep schedule is fucking horrendous um i
haven't had a normal sleep schedule in so long i try to fix
it for a while but um it hasn't been working because i've
been a degenerate for so long back to back to back to back
that um that like it honestly i'm just oh my gosh it's gonna
take a bit to rebuild myself it really it really really is
all right let me read you sorry mr.
man we read your messages out to all these people these
extra stuff ma'am domain and whatnot so like i'm making sure
there's no potential security issues rea and into open that
okay no actually we'll be so fucked up
i opened the floodgates and then i whoa whoa donkey got
hacked and i was like what how what you mean me rushing mr
man to open the store and not looking at the safety
precautions actually made me get hacked?
Whoa.
Really?
No way.
This is what it means to be an indie.
Actual concern about website security?
What the fuck?
Also, for those who don't know, there is going to be a
limited uh so like um there's gonna be new things for the uh
merch i've added some new stuff there for one um i added a
limited uh bundle of the rock was it sorry rock rob a bank
bundle and um it's only limited to like a hundred stock and
um it's only limited to a hundred stock And it has a signed
postcard, like hand signed postcard from me.
But it's like, I think that's right.
I don't remember what I wrote.
But I guess so don't, I don't know.
I've, I haven't.
Oh my god, no, wait.
Okay, so like I'm so fucked with the Etsy.
There's so many orders.
Thank you guys so much for the support.
Thank you, everybody.
I but also I'm so fine I have 200 plus orders oh my god um
to like my mom and I to package and everything there's 200
plus orders for my mom and I to package and uh can you be no
what the Can't it be sad by Mr. What the fuck?
You met Mr. Man today!
Like, what?
What the fuck do you mean?
Someone's like, That's all I need.
One day is all I need for Mr. Man.
Uh.
Wait, get me a sec.
All right.
No, you can put yours.
Um, but anyway, uh...
I guess, like, do you want this?
And I was like, uh, yeah.
And he's like, oh, I was doing it anyway.
Just, just asked to be polite, but he already did it.
Um, but yeah, so for the limited bundle, it'll be a hundred
for a sign...
an extra bonus sign postcard and then I guess I can spoil
you guys for what the Lunar New Year merch is going to mean.
So we're going to have the acrylic stand and a... Oh, okay.
So like, I tell you, I used to do Artist Alley.
So I actually have a button, those button makers and woo!
They pay it's a lot of work.
I actually hand make those buttons so we're gonna have those
like pin back buttons because I actually really like hand
making them because they're really fun because they're like
boom boom like they're really fun to do um but yes it's
gonna have the those button pin back buttons for the lunar
new year march and like those like little not little sorry
those cushions like the uh those cushions and stuff uh like
the uh there's like gonna be a cushion and also also we're
gonna have the red pocket envelope which is my favorite my
favorite part about all of this i'm so excited you should
buy the red pocket envelope to give it to whoever's married
so they can use that to give money to you it pays itself you
know or or send a link to whoever is like to all your
married friends relatives and like parents and it'd be like
i will only accept your money if you use a dokeybird
you don't have to pay for the envelope and you get the
envelope and you get like extra money too so it's like you
know free shit so
that's it that's life hack but only for like anyone that
celebrates lunar new year life hack oh yes oh yes for those
who are wondering is youtube going to be my main platform
youtube will be my main i like how this this is not even
this is not this was not an informative stream this is not
an informative stream it's like hey dokey's back she's gonna
fucking explain a lot of stuff and then and then all that
stuff information and And then here I am talking about
Roblox, Warrior Cats, and fucking all that other shit.
In between.
It's like going through like 30 minutes of ads before you
get to the what you want type deal.
It's like, if you want to learn more, go through the 30
minute ads of fucking Roblox, Warrior Cats RP.
No skipping.
Whoa.
Ad block doesn't work here.
Yeah.
Anyway, after I said all of that, I actually forgot what I
was trying.
Oh, yes, main platform.
Main platform will be YouTube.
And I will also be planning on...
I will be planning on streaming on Twitch as well as Billy
Billy.
So, but it's not going to be like...
It's just like, you know, in the past.
It's not like a common thing being on...
uh on those two say you know the best part okay i'm gonna
see i want i'm almost gonna be very curious if like because
like my old twitch account um i've already hit like partner
requirements and no it's not gonna be a simulcast i i don't
like that i don't i personally i personally don't like oh my
god you know uh i don't even guys remember you know um but
she actually reached out and said she'd help me with uh with
making with making an account so um so i really appreciate
it too um but yes anyway what i'm gonna say my twitch i've
actually hit twitch partner long long long ago and i never
got it because all i did was send in the b movie script oh
dokey maybe you stop sending the fucking B-movie script to
the Twitch staff.
Maybe you do what I've got, Twitch partner.
So, um, I was, um, I think I applied like three to four
times or something.
I got rejected every time because all I did was just send in
the B-movie script to them.
Repeatedly, yes.
Repeatedly.
And so, because of that, um, they rejected me, like, three
to four times and um but i still am eligible to reapply so i
was thinking wow if i do one stream on it maybe we'll take
it would it would they give me partner and so i can have i
need to figure out emotes too also i need to figure out how
the emotes and like i need to get emotes only i I get so
Your mom told you not to spend So much money anymore
I still can't believe I spent 200,000 and 100 How am I so
stupid?
Remember where I was like I stopped looking at my bank
account when I'm spending money?
What the fuck was wrong with me?
I'm just...
I just really...
I just want to have fun with all of you guys.
And I always wanted to...
I love doing it!
Okay, anyway, sorry.
Sorry I got into...
I got way too...
That fucked me up.
I'm sorry.
It's like a little...
It's like a trigger.
for me every time every time I think about it I oh it
doesn't make me angry it makes me I'm just so fucking stupid
I'm just like I'm I was like you didn't make any profit I
was like
that just that just that fucked me up that actually that
That, that actually, that actually fucked me up.
And we're fucking finding that out.
Oh my god.
Mr. Matt, what the fuck is the website?
I talked for like two hours.
This has been a two-hour fucking ad.
A two-hour unskippable ad.
this site sucks I just bought the sub but it won't let me
buy it we don't need to go live we don't need the domain
we'll get the domain later we can always get the domain
later we'll figure it out later anyway cat escape mr man is
doing his best doing please understand don't worry he likes
it if I know my chat if I know my chat
it's fine is that how what okay I swear to God if I put a
poll right now and I was like do you want me to yell at you
I swear to god like i know people be like no don't let her
win don't let her don't let her get hang again whatever she
wants i swear to god you guys would still vote yes like 100
you know if i can pull in a poll i'll be like do you want
doki to yell at you and then you guys would be like oh my
god Yes.
That should have been me.
Do...
Mr. M.
Do you want Doki to yell at you?
Alright.
Here you go.
I...
Like, you can't deny that.
Yeah.
True.
She's like, I'm doing it.
No.
I don't.
My ears.
would hurt yeah but like it's like
you know it's like that you know um i won't say it though
that's that's okay that's why that's what the poll is for
that's what it's for all right guys it's gonna be scouts but
like the store when it goes live it does not have a I just
wanted to put this I just wanted to put this story We'll fix
it later
We'll fix this I had two days
It's great I can always use that excuse For everything I do
now I can always use that excuse I had two days So we will
We will fix it post do not worry do not uh the store is
gonna go live and chat's gonna instantly yeah i'm never okay
honestly like i i like pre-ordered like 50 because i don't i
didn't okay when my when my therapist was like how many
people are you expecting to watch and i was just like oh i
don't know i Maybe like, I don't know, if it's going to be
really high, it might be like 50k.
Like, maybe I think, because of, you know, all that stuff
that happened.
And then he's like, whoa!
So then I was like, how many people will buy merch if 50,000
people are going to watch me?
I'll pre-order 50.
In my mind, I was like, okay if 50 000 people are gonna
watch me that means 50 people would want merch so like so i
already in advance because there's was like a lunar new year
discount um there was a lunar uh lunar new year discount um
at this manufacturer because like i i'm handling all the
that stuff and like coordinating all that stuff so so i was
like they're like oh how much you want away and i was like
50 that seems like a lot of people that buy my merch and i
was just like yeah and now i'm like now i'm a little worried
because now i'm like oh no what if what if 50 is just a
little bit too too little just a little bit under
just oh man maybe 50 is just you know just a little bit
under so don't worry i that's why it's a pre-order so i can
order more i will or it's a pre-order so i won't now i know
not to order in advance because I'm just gonna go buy
pre-orders for this.
So like, do not worry about that because it will be going by
pre-orders.
So it's not like I only have 50 in stock.
Maybe, you know, I don't know.
Maybe I'll get 60.
Whoa.
That'll be fucking insane.
Holy shit.
Maybe 60 people will buy my merch.
but don't worry it's uncapped except for the limited edition
bundle where if the signed postcards that is capped to a
hundred because a hundred is the limit i will sign a
postcard um because that is a lot of postcards That is just,
you know, a little, that's a lot.
That's still a lot.
And I really, I don't really want to get, how is it called,
when you fuck up your wrists?
Carpool Tunnel?
Yeah, I really don't want to get a Carpool Tunnel because,
you know, I play FPS shooters.
And, like, Carpool Tunnel is where FPS players die.
So, if I, oh, I shouldn't say that.
No!
Wait, no, I shouldn't.
That's why I shouldn't.
I go to therapy now.
I'm okay.
I couldn't.
You know, sometimes you gotta be able to laugh.
Sometimes you gotta be able to laugh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Anyway.
Mr. Matt, what the fuck?
Where?
not free birds i swear you we can come up with better names
free birds is a fucking okay i'm gonna say it it's a good
song but it's you can make it your fucking national anthem
if you want but we're not gonna be called free birds because
look i've been in this game for a while now okay like we've
came up with a solid name last time we can do it again I
know what makes a good name But like free birds is not a
good free like it's not a good fan mascot name We can do
better I know we can No you just Do you see a bot that says
like three to four years like what the fuck do you mean I
want to be the toky brokies No what the fuck We had two
days.
All right.
We're not going to be free birds.
I swear to fucking God.
We're not.
Wait, no, that's not.
No, I was going to say Chirpians.
It's pretty clever, but like, it's not.
It's pretty dumb.
If you say it out loud, if you say it out loud, it's not the
best name.
It's cool to read it.
Uh, the bird brigade.
Oh, look at that.
Do you want Doki to yell at you?
Yes, 83% yes.
And then people who are saying no are those who are fucking
in denial.
Alright, that's cool.
I told you guys.
I know you guys are fucking freaks.
But, you're my freak.
Alright, do it for...
Oh, shit, it's live.
What the fuck am I doing?
Okay, that's on me.
That's on me.
All right, so you guys know...
It says opening soon.
What...
Okay, guys.
Okay, when you see the URL...
It's like the theme of this entire my journey here too.
today it's it's actually this fucking theme of my this theme
of my very first tree okay let me say opening soon question
mark sorry I had to shoot me to the left again all right
okay let me refresh and see if that helps all right when you
see the URL of this store
you will understand where we're at in life you know i feel
it just fits where i'm at in life right now like and how
i've been feeling the past month honestly it's it's like
we're there we're there we made it we're we're existing it's
it's happening
It's...
Why does it say opening soon?
I like how I wrote opening soon and then silence and then
silence.
Alright, give me a sec.
Why is it called Doki Works?
Oh, because we don't have a...
We don't have our own domain.
Doki Mons is cute.
Go, go, dookimons.
Dookimons.
No, because I don't want you guys to be called dookies.
Like, there can only be one dookie.
I thought about it, but like, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I literally renamed my dog.
I literally gave him a nickname.
You're not taking dookie from me.
All right, I really, really, I renamed him to Doki Amber
Doge.
So, like, you're not taking, you're not taking Doki from me.
Yeah, I gave him dad, the Chirp Knights.
Oh, my God.
Chirp Knights.
Come here, Chirp Knight.
No, I can't say that.
Chirp Knights.
No, it just doesn't, it's so hard.
It's so hard finding, like, the perfect name it really is
wingman yeah but then like trucking then you'd be it's like
I don't want to fucking I don't want to draw a grown ass man
it's just like the most detailed like macho man out there
because like that's what I
um let's see the back seaters bro who said now we yeah i'm
not you guys are not gonna be get the mascot man the mascot
will just be one man please man standing still the welcome
no we're not doing freebirds hello freebirds no it's so
stupid bird seed oh my god why are your name so hard this is
like my third time doing this why i shouldn't be oh i should
be better there's more of you now there's more of you surely
there should be more ideas that's how fucking group work
works Oh no, actually, GroupWorks is the more there is.
The more people there are, the more people that's just going
to make one person do all the work.
You're not going to be the...
You're not going to be little tomatoes.
What the fuck?
I'm going to just squish you.
Freak.
No.
Because apparently, Zoomers ruined the word goons now.
so what was it yeah i heard i heard that i saw like people
started zoomers did something not zoomers what was it um
what are the ones after zoomers now where are they z wait
who what i mean sorry zoomers who what who's what's after
what's after zoomers already it's been a while Gen Alpha I
heard Gen Alpha ruined Gen Alpha ruined Goons so We cannot
have We cannot have that in there anymore We cannot have
that Anymore
Alright What?
Mr. Man I swear Mr. Man is having the fucking Hardest time
opening Up this door
it's like it's like why is it so hard no it says opening
soon
it's like okay face what's going on is that it's what's
going on is that we solve run problem and then it leads to
another problem and then we solve that problem and then it
goes to another problem and then he's just like why?
It's still opening soon.
What do you want from me?
Bird Knights.
Okay, I actually thought about bird knights but like it's
not a great name when you say it.
When you when you say say it aloud bird nights because like
you can't say bird nights very like if you say bird nights
very fast it's like it it sounds that's what it's saying
getting the perfect name is like what who the fuck said
nesticle what the fuck are you i don't have members so now
it's harder to find people now it hooter my hooters Fuck!
No, wait, no.
No, don't be tempted.
No, sorry.
That actually...
That's...
Welcome to...
Welcome, Hooters.
No, no, we shouldn't be.
I can't.
It's funny, but...
It's funny, but we can't be Hooters, guys.
As much as we can have transformative work now, we cannot be
Hooters.
That would...
Not be ideal for...
for it.
Deagles is good because of the emo.
You mean Doki Bark?
Oh my god.
I would, okay, I was so fucking I would say I was very
clever but like, I would, okay so like, so my Twitch tag,
like the emo like stuff, you have, it's like Doki B.
So then I had like I would actually make real words out of
it like Doki Bark.
Doki Bang, which is like Doki with a gun.
Doki Bread.
I would have like real...
I would just make real words out of my emotes, like, emotes
names and stuff.
I love Doki Bang.
Doki Bang is like one of my...
Also, like, okay, we're gonna have real emotes, but back
then, I just...
Back then, all I did was just...
I took a picture of my dog, and then I just drew...
expressions on
I was a very low effort streamer oh my god it's a very I
took a picture of my dog and then I just drew like
expressions on top of it and like photoshopped like items on
on on it on the emo and then my sub badges was just me
drawing the sub badges in MS Paint and then I just snip I
just crop crop it and then I just upload it and then
sometimes you can see my cursor on the sub badge and the sub
badges would be like the default sub badges but like MS
paint and then that's why I never thought I will get this
many people to watch me because holy fuck I was so lazy I
was so lazy
holy fuck i i was i did not care i didn't i just all i cared
was to talk to i just wanted to talk to people that's all i
cared this is why i never got twitch partner for fucking
five four times after applying for four tat three or four
times this is why i never got twitch partner
Jesus Christ We're not gonna be Nesticles Alright, we're
gonna, we're gonna shimmy to the I'll fix this later I'm
gonna shimmy to the left a little bit You know what, fuck
this Mr. Man, how long you think it's gonna take How long Do
you think it's This has been a two hour plus ad
That's been a two hour plus ad Plus ad That was unskippable
for 90,000 people.
It's been 80 hooligans.
No, wait.
I feel like someone's hooligan.
No, not that.
Aviators.
Best ad ever.
Nightingale.
Oh my god, nightingale.
Oh, there's so many syllables.
Nightingales.
Hello, my nightingales.
Nah, sorry.
That's way too.
Uh...
At this point, I don't know.
I think there's some info that might take time to process.
What?
Wait!
Why can't we...
Why can't we not have a domain?
Okay, why do we need domain just go live
he's like because the thing won't update and my billing info
okay guys guys most likely the shop might not go the shop
might not go live today apparently Because we're in We're,
it's It's been rough.
But I'll Show you guys the fucking URL because it's so
Fucking It's so funny.
I saw the URL and I was just like What the fuck?
Oh my god Look at this.
Look at this URL.
It doesn't show up.
The header doesn't show up Because it's not live.
He's like, he's like, can you please show, can you please
show your chat the header that I worked so hard on?
I can't see it.
Okay, they will see it when the shop, look, he's watching my
stream.
They will see it when the shop is live.
Anyway, it's not live, but like, this is what the shop looks
like.
You are.
Because we couldn't buy the domain.
Like, I was just like, what the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Look at my, look at my URL.
Truly.
And this is why I'm an indie now.
You can tell I'm an indie.
professional you are it's opening soon by the way soon TM
not the Shopify uh yes thank you I am thank you what do you
mean we suck I ain't delicate in the task to you
drag me into this I delegated this task to you oh my god
okay to be fair we did not expect that so many we did okay
to be fair we did not expect so many emails that google
locked my business account because there was too many emails
who the fuck expects that like i've never had that happen to
me before there is so many emails Like, Google just locked
it, so it never...
So then I had to change it to, like, his personal email.
Because they were like, what the fuck is wrong with your
email account?
Is it a bot?
And I'm like, oh, fuck.
I'm like, I did not expect so many things.
And also, guys, I'm sorry.
I saved the website because we can't...
Get it.
We couldn't launch it.
We couldn't.
I don't think I can launch it by...
I really don't think I can launch it by the end of the
stream.
Because this has been...
This...
This has took a very long time to try and get to work.
But...
When...
When the- I'm not gonna play a game!
I'm not gonna play a game!
That's my first- I said the first game I'm gonna do.
I'm not gonna play Neo Pets right now.
I said the very first game I'm gonna do.
I will play- I'm playing Neo Pets.
I'm not- Oh my god.
My manager literally told me the- This- He told me to watch
TikTok.
Like, what the fuck?
Wait, look.
Okay.
Alright.
What do you mean, figure it out?
Figure it out, Mr. Manager?
Alright.
Ah, fuck it.
Okay.
We'll figure this out after the stream.
And then...
And then I'll tweet it out.
I'll tweet it out.
When it goes live.
Oh, that sucks for you guys.
Because there's like a hundred of the limited stock thing.
And like I feel like you guys are going to.
Oh my gosh.
You guys might try to fight for it.
So please.
We'll try not.
We'll try and give you guys a heads up.
Before it actually goes live.
okay no because we're gonna might change the domain later on
but i changed it because i was like thinking like oh no now
you guys are gonna camp the domain and refresh my lovely
4-3d 9b 2-2 domain my love you guys you're just gonna
refresh the 4-3d 9b 2-d2 domain like link just to see go up
um so thank you thank you it's it's a beautiful name oh my
gosh oh my fucking what a all right I think I think it's
serious time all right it's it's serious time okay it's it's
it's it's the serious time hour now Alright, uh, okay.
I actually wrote, pre-wrote this.
I pre-wrote this statement in advance.
Um, anyway.
Alright, alright.
Oh my god.
I have to be serious now.
After, it was nice just, you know, hang out and just, um,
but this is a, I only talk about this once.
Um, I want to talk about this once.
And, and then we.
move forward and celebrate Lunar New Year and New
Beginnings.
Ah, okay.
I'm just gonna read this.
Okay.
So, as y'all know, when the announcement dropped, I was just
as surprised as all of you.
And, um, I only found out because a friend messaged me and I
didn't even know what was in it.
And I read it for the first time when I went public.
When I still know that I did try to leave neutral.
Because I knew it would be very bad for everyone involved if
it went to the last possible route.
And I tried.
I really did try to try and make it neutral.
And I did get a lawyer because my emergency contact and I
couldn't really handle it anymore especially when I was
still recovering and I was lucky that I had a statement made
in advance which my lawyer helped edit in case this did
happen so I could respond instantly the statement that was
posted was written so I'd be safe and I can move forward and
restart my life while being stuck in limbo forever.
And I wouldn't have made the statement if the announcement
didn't go up the way it did.
And I was willing to keep the info hidden to the public.
And I never truly wanted the public to know why I was in the
hospital.
But I had to respond with the truth when it did went out.
And I know there's a lot of people that wish for me to
clarify or explain more, but I honestly can't.
And I'm sorry.
And these are the things that I can say though.
I was in the hospital for an attempt.
And I provided medical documents of everything that happened
to prove it as well.
As the therapy sessions afterwards.
evaluation.
Everyone knew I was in the hospital and the reason behind it
a few days before I was discharged and I was not referencing
something that happened once that pushed me to it but it was
a build-up that stemmed for multiple months that led to my
breaking point.
I would never make this claim to a proof or confirmation and
only did so that my lawyer looked through the proof and and
agreed it was happening in multiple months from what I
showed.
I honestly wish I could have met you all one last time and I
cried when I found that I couldn't.
And I hope I can still meet you on the future even if I'll
be a little different.
My final note on all of this is let's not harass or bully
anybody.
I already know how that felt.
and i want us to be adults and not make it high school and i
want to move on focus on us succeed and be better and the
lunar new year is coming and it's two new beginnings and
it's time to leave the past behind us and make new memories
like this entire stream i have so many ideas i still want do
and i really do want to make all you laugh for as long as i
can and i think from this entire stream that you guys can
tell that i'm still me and they can never really take that
away so yeah that was the statement that i wrote for this
stream and the The two-hour ad is finally over.
I think that's like a huge weight off my shoulder.
And it's time to move forward.
And celebrate Lunar New Year.
Yeah!
I mean, we could celebrate early.
Alright, where is it?
Alright,
when you were a little kid, your parents' fucking relatives
will always force you to do that fucking song and just be
like, look at how cute they are.
And then you do it because you're a greedy fuck that wants
more red pocket envelope.
You're a kid and you celebrate Lunar New Year.
I think it's just an Asian thing, maybe.
We had true.
We were given forward about the harsh reality of money as a
very young age.
But yeah, I need it.
I know it was a very serious statement, but I still want to
laugh with all of you.
I still want to make jokes because if I don't make these
jokes, Um, then it just gets too real.
And we're here to, you know, where life is short and I have
hope for the future now.
And thank you, everybody.
I don't, you guys don't have a name yet, so I don't know
what to call you guys.
Anyway.
Thank you, everybody.
I enjoyed...
I really did...
I really enjoyed today's stream.
Just talking with all of you.
Being...
Doing this all over again.
And...
Let's get to 500k subscribers, buddy.
End of the year!
Yeah!
That's my wish.
I just realized...
Oh my god, Toki, July 4th, your birthday.
That's like two birthdays.
If you think about it.
Oh my god, your birthday came back so fast!
Woo!
Isn't that great?
um how do we know that's your real birthday this time we
fucked up if i wasn't even my real birthday and i was just
like i want my birthday fasty
um but yes everybody as always everybody say hi jaded
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing any of you stay up for me head to bed because you
deserve it i'll See you guys next time, everybody.
Bye.